PROFESSOR: You first are facing
the calculation of the energy
eigenstate with some
arbitrary potential.
You probably want to know some
of the key features of the wave
functions you're
going to calculate.
So in fact, all
of today's lecture
is going to be devoted to this
intuitive, qualitative insights
into the nature of
the wave function.
So we will discuss
a few properties
that help us think clearly.
And these are two
of those properties.
I want to begin with them.
Then we'll do a third one
that we have already used,
and we will prove it completely.
And then turn to the classical
and semi-classical intuition
that lets us figure out how
the wave function will look.
And that's a great help for you.
Even if you're solving for
your wave function numerically,
you always need to know what
the answer should look like.
And it's ideal if before you
calculate, you think about it.
And you realize, well, it
should have this t properties.
And if you find out
that those are not true,
well, you will learn
something about your intuition
and see what was wrong with it.
So we're talking about one
dimensional potentials, time
independent potentials.
And a first statement
that is very important,
and you will prove in an
exercise after spring break,
and that is the fact that one
dimensional potentials, when
you look at what are
called bound states,
you never find degeneracies,
energy degeneracies.
And this is when x extends from
minus infinity to infinity.
You've seen already, in the
case of a particle in a circle,
there are degenerate
energy eigenstates.
But if the potential
extends to infinity,
there is no such things.
Now what is a bound state?
A bound state sounds like
a complicated concept.
But it is not.
It really means an
energy eigenstate
that can be normalized.
Now if an energy eigenstate
can be normalized
and you live in
the full real line,
that the wave function
must go to 0 at infinity.
Otherwise you would never
be able to normalize it.
And if the wave function
goes 0 at infinity,
the bound state is some sort
of bump in the middle region
or something like that.
And it eventually decays.
So this is bound by the
potential in some way.
And that's basically what we
use to define a bound state.
We'll take it to
be that generally.
So this is something,
this property,
which is very important, is
something you will prove.
But now we go to
another property.
We've emphasized forever
that the Schrodinger equation
is an equation with
complex numbers.
And the solutions
have complex numbers.
And suddenly, I wrote
a few lectures ago
a wave function was real.
And I was asked, well,
how can it be real?
Well, we've discussed stationary
states in which the full wave
function, capital PSI, is
equal to a little psi of x
times the exponential of e
to the minus i et over h bar.
And there in that
exponential, there
is complex numbers
on this little psi
of x in front of that
exponential, which
is what we called basically
those energy eigenstates.
The e to the minus
i et over h bar,
it's understood
that little psi of x
is the thing we've
been looking for.
And this psi of x solves the
time independent Schrodinger
equation h psi equal e psi.
And that equation has
no complex number in it.
So little psi of x can be real.
And there's no contradiction.
Because the full
solution to the time
dependent Schrodinger
equation is complex.
But here is a statement.
With v of x real, the
energy eigenstates
can be chosen to be real.
And the words can be chosen
are very important here.
It means that you may find
a solution that is complex,
but you need not stick
to that solution.
There is always a possibility
to work with real solutions.
And what is the
way you prove this?
This I will put
this in the notes.
You don't have to
worry about the proof.
You consider the Schrodinger
equation for psi.
And you show that psi star,
the complex conjugate of psi,
solves the same equation
that psi solves.
And therefore, if
psi is a solution,
psi star is a solution
with the same energy.
That part is very important.
Therefore, if you have
two energy eigenstates
with the same energy,
you can form the sum.
That's still an
energy eigenstate
with the same energy.
Even formed in
difference, that's
still an energy eigenstate
with the same energy.
And the sum of psi
plus psi star is real.
And the difference psi minus
psi star, if you divide by 2i,
is real as well.
Therefore you can construct two
solutions, the real part of psi
and the imaginary part of psi.
And both are solutions to
the Schrodinger equation.
So I've said in words what is
the proof of the first line.
It's that if you have a psi,
psi star is also a solution.
Therefore, psi plus psi
star and psi minus psi star
are solutions.
So given a complex
psi, then psi psi of x.
Then psi real of x that
we define to be psi
of x plus psi star of x over 2.
And the imaginary
part of the wave
function 1 over 2i
psi of x minus psi
star of x are both solutions
with the same energy
as this one has.
So these are the two solutions.
So far so good.
You don't like to
work with complex psi?
No need to work
with complex psi.
Work with real psi.
But here comes the second
part of the argument,
the second sentence.
I want you to be alert
that the second sentence is
very powerful.
It says that if you have
a bound state of a one
dimensional potential,
more is true.
There are no genuinely complex
solutions in this case.
Any solution that you will
find, it's not that it's complex
and then you can find the
real and imaginary part.
No, any solution that you will
find will be basically real.
And how can it fail to be real?
It just has a complex
number in front of it
that you can ignore.
So it is a very
strong statement.
That the wave function, it's not
that you can choose to work it.
You're forced to do
it up to a phase.
So how is that possible?
How is that true?
And here is the argument
for the second line.
If we're talking bound
states, then these two
are real solutions
with the same energy.
So now suppose these
are bound states.
There is a problem if there
are two real solutions
with the same energy.
They would be degenerate.
And property number
1 says there's
no such thing as degenerate
energy bound states.
So they cannot be degenerate.
So if you start with a complex
psi, and you build these two,
they must be the same solution.
Because since there are no
degenerate bound states,
then psi, I will write
it as psi imaginary,
of x must be proportional
to psi real of x.
And both are real, so
the only possibility
is that they are equal
up to a constant,
where the constant
is a real constant.
You see there cannot be
degenerate bound states.
So the two tentative
solutions must be the same.
But that means that the
original solution, psi,
which is by definition
the real part plus i
times the imaginary
part, is now equal to psi
r plus i times c
times psi r again,
which is 1 plus ic times psi r.
And that is basically the
content of the theorem.
Any solution is up to a
number, just the real solution.
So you're not going to
find the real solution has
non-trivial different
real imaginary parts here.
No, just the real solution
and a complex number.
Now if you want,
you can just write
this as e to the i argument of
1 plus ic times square root of 1
plus c squared psi r.
And then it's literally
the way it's said here.
The wave function is
proportional to a real wave
function up to a phase.
So that's a very neat situation.
And therefore, you
should not be worried
that we are going to
have to assume many times
in our analysis that
the bound states were
trying to look for are real.
And we plot real bound states.
And we don't have to worry
about, what are you plotting?
The real part?
The imaginary part?
Many times we can just
work with real things.